view anyway. And then we had the
corrected version of the numbers which
went down to about 22 to they were the
names of people. They were the ones they
could put a name to. They don't know how
many people are lying in rubble still.
They have no idea. People have been
killed. People have been killed in
gigantic numbers week in week out. You
know that and I know that. I've
interviewed doctors. I've interviewed
doctors in hospitals saying,
just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran. Gives you reminders. Download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your Makyama that you read it
wherever you was. Welcome to Brothers
and sisters and dear friends. Pers
Morgan has become propalinian all of a
sudden overnight. Subhan Allah. Brother
and sisters, we're going to be reacting
this video, inshallah, to uh one
Zionist, shameless woman, a witch. She
looks like a witch uh you know, and
subhan Allah, a a pro Palestinian
activist who is having a debate in topic
in oddly Pierce Morgan is pro
Palestinian today. Okay, let's see.
Let's find out in here's the video in
Let's get straight into it, brothers and
sisters. In you seem to be a little
obsessed with this country. I'm obsessed
with how many civilians have been
killed. Okay. All right. Let's say we
take the so-called Gaza Health
Ministries numbers, the corrected
version. Do you remember what that is
now? That was the number of people they
could actually put a name to, right?
Corrected. The correct they could put a
name to. So, we went and you think
that's the total number of civilians
killed. We The last time I was on your
show, you had um Bagouti saying that
there was 40, 50, 60,000 dead. Let's
just add numbers on because why not?
Everybody will believe you anyway. And
then we had the corrected version of the
numbers which went down to about 22 to
they were the names of people. They were
the ones they could put a name to. They
don't know how many people are lying in
rubble still. They have no idea. People
have been killed. People have been
killed in gigantic numbers week in week
out. You know that and I know that. I've
interviewed doctors I've interviewed
doctors in hospitals saying 500 people
are being brought in every single day.
But what staggers me, Flur, what
staggers me is that you, like the
government spokesman I interviewed, you
are certain you know exactly how many
terrorists you're killing, but you no
idea how many civilians. Let me bring
you how big they are. I mean, uh, it's
it's amazing. You know, the way she
makes it seem as if the numbers are been
wrong apparently according to her
because anything that comes out
objective news is false. Um it's as if
it was like the numbers were 230 and
then the Hamas members came and said
only two 300 Palestinians killed and
they made it out to be 40 50,000 100 200
fold. Oh yeah she's saying no it's just
it's 22,000 or something like that and
you can clearly see sisters that is
because that is the people that have got
name to nobody knows how many people are
under the rubble. Have you guys seen
Gaza? Have you seen the image of Gaza?
Imagine how many people are still under
the rubble. You shameless dirt bags. you
Zionist, this the end. This is the
beginning of the end for Israel,
inshallah. Let's carry on. This is my
problem with when I when I get into
numbers with the Israeli side is that
they seem to be utterly emphatic in
their knowledge of how many terrorists
they're killing, but no idea how many
civilians and almost don't care. It's
the fog of war. Churchill didn't count.
The fog of war was used by the UN, not
us. When they when they when they were
asking when they were justifying the
wrong, that was their expression.
Let him speak, please.
And again, once again, they know exactly
how many terrorists they killed.
Apparently, you know, remember at one
point they were saying half of those
50,000 that's massacred, half of them
are Hamas. Bull crap. Absolute nonsense.
They know how many terrorists they
killed, but they don't know how many
civilians.
It's not that they almost don't care,
PICE. It's that they don't care. And we
know that the number is probably higher
than 36,000 people killed. You and I
have eyes. The world has eyes. We have
seen Rafa get bombed. We have seen the
charred bodies. We have seen Israel bomb
churches, mosques, refugee camps. We
have seen Israel kill the staff of World
Central Kitchen and then say, "Oops, we
have seen Israel occupy Palestinians in
the West Bank. There's no Hamas in the
West Bank." What's Israel's excuse for
killing over 500 people in the West Bank
with Ben handing out handing out excuse
me with Ben Gavir handing out weapons to
extremist? West Bank. You're do not if
you think of course you know West Bank
exactly there is no Hamas in the West
Bank and they are still killing people
in the West Bank they still do not give
them their rights as you can see. Subhan
Allah. So brothers and sisters these
people are
just no shame like the prophetam said if
you have no shame do as you please and
that's exactly what they're doing but
only in this life in the on the day of
judgment you're going to you're going to
see inshallah you are going to see Allah
says inah the believers will be sitting
on reclining chairs and laughing back at
them and seeing if they have been paid
back for what they have done but to you
can I just say but to you Hamas doesn't
control the West Bank facts please but
to you Every Palestinian is a terrorist.
You don't care about the women. You
don't care about the children. You don't
care about the majority of people that
have been killed are civilians. To you,
it's all
terrorists. This is
the accused. I can judge you by Can I
just finish? I let you I didn't say a
word. Can you let him finish his point?
Don't keep talking over him. Flur. Let
him finish his point. First of all,
well, he listened to you. She So, let
him speak. She rep, this is what I say
is she represents the general
psychopathy of the Israeli government
where they come on television and they
think the rest of the world actually is
like them that they don't see
Palestinians as humans and they say
these talking points and pier sometimes
when you invite me to debate I sit here
and go I don't have to say a word
because they are undermining themselves
and their own cause in front of the
global stage right now. I mean, the fact
that she knows by like somehow magically
they're all terrorists, but when you ask
them repeatedly, well, how can you not
know how many civilians there are and
they say, "Well, we we we don't know
what civilians." And then she goes to
World War II, compares Palestinian moms
and children to Germans, to Nazis. Okay,
fine. Go for it. You That is so valid.
Um because in Israel, they don't see
Palestinians as humans. That's why you
see podcast people saying, "If I could
press the button and wipe out Gaza, I
would do that." Generally inside Israel,
they do not see Palestinian babies.
You've seen your general layman, Israeli
Zionists mocking the deaths, literally
mocking people who are dying and being
massacred. They don't see Palestinians
as humans. Not only that, she's equating
the Nazi German the World War II. The
real Nazis are you guys. You are the
real Nazis. You guys are the real Nazis.
And you equating the Palestinians to be
Nazis. You can't make this up. The
irony. The irony. You are the real
Nazis. That's been recorded in 4K HD.
The whole world can see what kind of
vile Zionist scums you guys are. Talking
about mosques and you're talking about
churches and you're talking about
schools and you failed to mention that
that's exactly where kamas hide. Not
just that, they build mosques on top of
tunnels, on top of terrorist
installations. You want to ignore the
fact that Hamas are cynically using
their own people. They use their people
as a defense strategy. They're using our
hostages. So, Israel bombs Rafa and
kills kids.
So, Israel bombs world central kitchen
staff. Terrorists. Israel bomb two
terrorists a kilometer away. There was a
fire that was made by munitions that
were in a place that they shouldn't have
been. And that's actually you don't know
all that. You don't know that. That's
not been established as an ongoing
investigation. That's not sorry. But all
I know is again to correct you either.
You don't know what happened either. No,
nor do. So you accept you don't. We are
at the moment in you just accepted. You
don't. We know that it was a kilometer
away from where you just said you didn't
know what happened either. In other
words, nor do you. We are we are doing
an investigation. Right. It's not
concluded. So how she can say these
things are fact. And then bear in mind,
she just said Pierce called called her
out. Finally, Pierce. But again, listen,
you're not on the right side of history,
by the way, my friend. Yeah. Just
because you're speaking out about now.
Let me tell you something. Called her
out. She doesn't know. She's chatting
nonsense. When they're called out, she
actually doesn't know. She's acted as
she knows. Now, she's being called out
by peers that she doesn't know. Look
what she says next. Check this out. The
only fact, the only fact, if I may
finish, if I may finish, if I may
finish, flirting. If I may finish, if I
may finish, the only fact is that 45
innocent people in the refugee camps
were killed at the same time as
apparently two Hamas terrorists. I don't
call that a very good percentage, do
you? No. But it wasn't a strategy. And
it is not when you bomb a refugee camp.
That is a strategy. When you bomb a
refugee camp, it is a strategy. Did not
bomb a refugee camp. We bombed two who
are in a refugee camp. They were a
kilometer away from the humanitarian.
They were in a refugee camp. They were
in a kilometer away from the
humanitarian. In a refugee camp where we
moved people in order to put them, you
move them there and then you killed
them. Hamas. Hamas keeps them in harm's
way. When babies were baked in ovens on
October 7th, that was a strategy. When
Israel tries to weed out the terrorists
and there are unfortunately casualties,
it's not a strategy. That is not what we
aim to do. Those casualties are beheaded
babies in Rafa that
really beheaded baby and babies were
beheaded. Her horrific babies. What
absolute lie? They're still spewing the
same lie. And she calls he calls she
calls him a liar. They are spewing the
same lie of babies being killed and
graping that happened and the 1,200
people died. It died because of your
hannibal directive. Your own soldiers
have admitted that you scum. You you
shameless individual. How shameless do
you have to be? Subh and now pe is
speaking after 50,000 died. But look,
check this out now. Watch remember she
said about the behead. She's like really
baby. She's shocked now. Oh really? Cuz
that really happened you know. Check
this out now. Watch watch watch how she
denied about it not happening. Watch
this now.
That's what happened in rough and you
know why they went to rougher period.
Hang on. Hang on. Accept it. Sir, just
to be clear, are you denying that there
were any video footage of of a baby
beheaded?
I have not seen anything and I know that
the Israeli army would never do anything
like seen anything. Look, look, listen
to me guys. She has not seen anything.
Remember when she's talking about the
baked babies, etc. in the October 7th,
etc. She didn't see nothing. She would
confirm it. confirm it without seeing
it. Lies were made here. She's like,
"No, I haven't seen it." Watch this now.
That No, sorry. The baby's head was
blown off. Oh, okay. Listen. When she
killed 36,000 Palestinians. Oh, okay.
Can you imagine how she's brushing off?
Oh, okay. Is that cuz she for actual
beheading means, you know, beheading
that happens? No, she's, you know, she's
like, "Oh, it got blown off." Oh, that's
fine. That's me thinking IDF soldiers
behead babies. Not that way. We behead
in different ways. We blow their brains
out. May Allah destroy you. fire that
raised through that refugee camp did
that damage to that baby was absolutely
and it was but it's going to happen
again and again if you bomb people in a
refugee camp well we weren't aiming to
bomb people in a refuge but you are
going to kill them if you keep dropping
bombs in a refugee camp aren't you
you're going to did you see she now
admitted she now admitted first denied
it then accept that she doesn't know now
she's like oh yeah it happens casualty
do you see What kind of liars they are?
So what kind of they are if you let
Okay, let me ask you this. We left the
Let me ask you this to their own. Let me
ask you this. Look what happens. Let me
please stop talking. If I'm asking a
question, my question is this. My
question is this. If there's no
occupation, how is it that at the start
of this war, Israel was able to turn off
a lot of the water into Gaza, a lot of
the food into Gaza, a lot of the energy
into Gaza? If you're not an occupying
country, how are you able to do that to
another country? A blockade is not an
occupation. What is it? And the A
blockade is not an occupation legally. A
blockade is what is it? Well, we we're
first of all, there's trade. There was
trade going on between Gaza and Israel
before October 7th. We gave out 20,000
work permits. People were working all
across. Why are Palestinians not
entitled to the same rights as Israelis?
They have their own They had their own
state. They don't have the rights of
Israelis. Why not? Because they're not
Israelis. Okay. Well, that's pretty
conclusive. Thank you. They're not
Israelis left in sometimes. You know
what? Look, the It's good to shine a
light because you get the right answer.
No, let me tell you what light I come
shining. The brother is going to point
out is Israel winning this war? No. And
on all grounds. Watch this. Now, I want
to just say those who are supporting the
war like she is. Here's the failure of
Netanyahu's order very quickly.
Netanyahu said he wants to destroy
Hamas. Hamas is not destroyed. Failure
number one. Netanyahu says he wants the
hostages back. The family members of the
hostages are protesting Netanyahu
because they know he doesn't care.
Failure number two. He says he wants to
make Israel safer. Israel is not safer.
He wants to make the region safer.
Region's not safer. He wants to help
Israel's reputation. Israel is a pariah.
Military solutions will not work. People
like your guest right now think they
could put the boot on the neck of
Palestinians. create a symmetry where
there is none. Occupy people and people
resist that occupation and just die.
They're just gonna die. They're not. If
you want an end, if you want peace, stop
the occupation and give Palestinians a
pathway towards self-determination. And
if there should be two states, Pierce,
riddle me this. Why is Israel expanding
settlements in the West Bank? What
excuse is it? Please, please give us the
excuse why Israel could not agree more
is occupying the West Bank and expanding
settlements. I couldn't agree more.
Flirt. Why on earth does Israel think
it's a good idea to expand settlements
on the West Bank? Well, first of all,
you have to understand the context that
Area A and B, which is where 94% of the
Palestinians live, are under the PA
autonomy. The fact that they haven't
developed their own economy, the fact
that they don't give people anything.
The fact that East Jerusalem, that's not
the question. The question is why expand
settlements knowing it is deeply
inflammatory and often accompanied by
violence. Why? Because the settlements
are not the obstacle to a two-state
solution. Actually, they're one of the
major obstacles actually. Yeah. Because
if you keep seizing
lands who are violent towards
Palestinians, that is an obstacle. Yeah,
it is. Not only the increase in the
settle settlements sisters, Ben Gav,
this dirt bag, may Allah destroy him in
this and
hereafter says 10,000 assault rifles
purchased for civilian security teams.
He's been giving out rifles and weapons
to these individuals who are abusing the
the Palestinians, Muslims and
Christians, by the way, who are living
under in Palestine, broisters. Subhan
Allah. So, I mean, the main point here
is this. Um, Pierers Morgan finally
after 50,000 deaths of pal Palestinians.
When it came to the Ukrainian thing,
when Russia killed a couple hundred,
etc., he was automatically genocide, you
name it. But when it comes to
Palestinians, the death toll has to be
higher. 50,000. Now, Pier Morgan is now
pro Palestinian. Now, we don't buy it,
my friend. We don't buy it. You are on
their side. You are not on our side. And
this video is to show that now you want
to come and talk. Shame on you. Shame on
you, brothers and sisters. If you want
more videos like this, send them to me
in I can react and dissect them for you.
Inshallah, brothers and sisters. And may
Allah bless you guys and protect our
brothers and sisters in Gaza and forgive
us for our shortcomings.